I like to cry I'd like to get my kids
going if I could I'll go out with my
eight-year-old if she's not like feeling
it give me a hug in the morning or kiss
I'll give it into the whole dad's
getting emotional no she'll come over I
came home new in theaters this weekend
instant family fantastic beasts the
crimes of Grindelwald and widows what
will you see this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
hey you're my family now instead family
comes out this weekend starring Mark
Wahlberg and Rose burns this
heartwarming comedy is directed by and
based on the real-life experiences of
Sean Anders with the original intent of
fostering one kid Pete and Ellie find
themselves all of a sudden with three
kids making them a family instantly
Lizzie comes with two younger siblings
three kids two my oh my god why would
you show us that that's wrong this movie
is for you if you love seeing intense
Mark Wahlberg inserted into family man
type roles a comedy about and for
families is what you need or you love
things that bring you instant
gratification like instant coffee Wi-Fi
or rip-away basketball warm-up pants
also in theaters this weekend fantastic
beasts the crimes of Grendel vol this is
the sequel to fantastic beasts and where
to find them and the 10th film in the
Wizarding World franchise that all
started with Scarface nope Harry Potter
rumors are true Grendel vault has
escaped to round up pure blood witches
and wizards and an effort to gain even
more power over non magical beings like
you this movies for you if you like
Eddie Redmayne Jude Law Johnny Depp Ezra
Miller zoe kravitz or any of the other
ensemble cast members you're obsessed
with or even only kind of like the Harry
Potter franchise or you believe that
justice is a dish best served by one
finally widows comes out this weekend
from director Steve McQueen this
emotional crime thriller is about the
lives of four thieves who must finish
the job their husband started after a
police shootout left them dead during a
failed robbery attempt
they stole a lot of money
and now people want it from us now the
best thing we have going for is is being
who we are why because no one thinks we
have the balls to pull this off this
movies for you if you love intense crime
thrillers you're down to see a
particularly great performance by Viola
Davis or you sometimes get annoyed by
your spouse leaving behind a mess that
you have to pick up I'm not married boy
that sounds terrible
that is your weekend ticket what will
you see check back next week for some
Michael B Jordan ABS
[Music]
[Music]
you